Korean food in Los Angeles now in
Koreatown is better than Korean food in
Korea the money here is so big that all
the best chefs and all the best cooks
have come to La you could just go to any
random place it's hard to get bad Korean
food here Koreatown they want to make it
look like Korea you know when you see a
building that's four or five stories
tall now there's three or four stories
underneath as well yeah I was born and
raised in Koreatown that's probably one
of the biggest [__] gentrified areas
and it was really about a square mile
Cape Town probably occupies more area
than Hollywood now it's like it's it's
ridiculous how far it stretches